I was thinking today with Trump's
inauguration coming up and the behavior
from the left just the contrast between
Barack Obama's inauguration particularly
in Hollywood in the entertainment
industry and in how people were really
they were demanding you come together
and how they wanted you to react as
Americans let's let's take a
time-travelling each of us resolves to
pitch it and look after not only
ourselves but each other I pledge I
pledge to be the voice for those that
have no voice to consider myself
American not an African American do you
always represent my country with pride
dignity and honesty to sell a culture of
intelligence instead of ignorance to
fight to become aware to educate to not
give up to defend issues that I care
about I pledge to be of service to
Barack Obama I pledge to commit to my
own change before I ask others to change
to be the change to be the change to
integrate into my heart what I already
know in my head which is that we're all
in this together
I pledge to be a servant to our
president and all mankind because
together we can together we are nice
there first off they're divorced always
want to take life advice from a part of
the world the endured a ministry the
only place with a virtually 100 percent
divorce rate but pledging allegiance to
a leader with Barack Obama doesn't it
seem reminiscent of Hitler comparison so
this was back a lot of y'all didn't
remember this they were talking about
unity and together and we need to give
this president to chance remember that
it's time let's get him
yes this is what matter this is what
they were telling us all in 2008 and
2009 there were dead set on it compare
that with the reaction to Trump's
upcoming inauguration
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it seems pretty mild please tell me
someone gets run over
now no one got run over oh it's such a
contrast it when we actually have we've
written about this at ladder with
Crowder project very to us has written
about this to a group disrupt j-20 was
actually planning to release noxious
gases to the ventilation system and
inauguration did you guys hear about
this so just a little just a little
dabbling in domestic terrorism is what
they're doing in project very to us had
a video were they actually I think we
have a clip they exposed undercover
plans they wanted to put pints of acid
in the sprinkler system for inauguration
let's see that really quickly
[Music]
what's so odd about that is when he's
sitting there you know he's sitting
there for a second he's looking like
this I'm watching I'm going oh he's he's
figured it out he's seen a camera and
then he goes on to describe how he would
commit acts of terrorism like he thought
oh oh he's aware he caught on so this is
how we're going to get people covered in
acid it's just the lack of self
awareness is amazing it's just it really
is incredible how we went from years and
years of them absolutely trashing bush
how many pictures of george w bush with
chimpanzee did you get forwarded oh gosh
and your email so many and then all of a
sudden civility civility was the virtue
above all other virtues Barack Obama
became president oh well we want a call
to civility we really think now it's
time to unify now it's time to be civil
and here's what's funny I think on this
show I hope if you watch the way we've
interviewed leftists on the show and
they usually do come back yeah I I value
civility of course I value kindness but
I value honesty over civility I value
integrity over politeness I value
consistency over political expediency I
value selflessness over economic
covetousness that you see from the left
so they go from civility civility and by
the way let me let me be very very clear
here I thought I will never pledged
allegiance to Donald Trump I thought it
was creepy back then and weird and
uncomfortable and I think it's creepy
and weird now I will certainly never
kneel for a man I hope nobody out there
in freedom loving America feels that way
and it will get complaints about this
sometimes you know I really I really
just you shouldn't criticize Donald
Trump at all because of the MSM the
lamestream media does that enough know
will criticize him when it's fair and
will support him one he's right because
we at least try and be consistent here
and I think the only way to beat the
left and you see this you see what they
did the pledge allegiance to Obama and
you see their behavior now I think the
only way to actually beat the modern
regressive less
left and there there they're almost
transparent at this point your political
expediency you saw that with Barack
Obama is to contrast that with
intellectual consistency and even if you
disagree with us that's what we're gonna
try and do here hopefully we do hey
speaking of horrible people if you like
this video subscribe by clicking the
button that says subscribe if you're not
aware of it now there's no way you're
learning the Internet at this point I'm
not going to help you but this was
clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with better calm
slash mug Club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand at mug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside